Back-end programmers often collaborate
with other types of programmers, and
they work in teams.
Each company and
team will be different, but generally,
back-end programmers may sync with
front-end programmers to support
any front-end features
that require storing or
retrieving data, like someone's name,
birthday, and favorite food.
They may also link with mobile
programmers to make data usable
in a mobile application.
Finally, they may also connect with data
analysts to create usable structures for
client data.
Back-end programmers play
an important role in teams.
In the next lesson, we will learn
more about mobile programming.